in the 1950s and 1960s the U.S Civil
Rights leader Malcolm X was considered a
dangerous man what Lincoln did never
said the black people in this country
free had its freed us we still wouldn't
be begging uh the president for civil
rights and things of that sort Malcolm
told his wife his calls for African
Americans to actively resist racist laws
would get him killed on February 21 1965
three men gunned him down in front of an
audience at the Audubon Ballroom in
Harlem Betty Shabazz said that because
of her husband's reputation as a fire
brand and black separatist it would be
nearly impossible to know who plotted
his killing now I guess they're taking
shot himself
58 years later Malcolm X's daughters are
accusing the New York Police Department
the FBI the CIA and New York State
officials of planning his murder and of
covering their tracks the family is
suing for 100 million dollars the truth
about the circumstances leading to the
death of our father is important not
only to his family but to many followers
many admirers the shabazzas and their
lawyer didn't offer details to support
their claim but they pointed out that
two men were wrongfully convicted for
Malcolm's murder had their records
cleared in 2021 and were compensated for
their time in prison
we intend to
have vigorous
litigation of this matter
to have discovery
to be able to take depositions
of the individuals who
are still alive
58 years later
to make sure
that some measure of Justice
can be given
to Malcolm X's daughters the white man
has to feel free to speak his mind
without hurting the feelings of that
negro and the so-called negro has to
feel free to speak his new mind without
hurting the feelings of the white man
it's been long known that authorities
spied on Malcolm X suspecting him of
being either a communist sympathizer or
a threat to white Americans or both the
NYPD won't comment on the pending
lawsuit Malcolm X's family hopes the
lawsuit will compel many to finally tell
what they know
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera